warning you may
never eat sugar again after watching
this video or at least you'll
dramatically cut down the amount of
sugar that you consume and i think
everyone knows that sugar is bad it
affects almost every part of your body
it causes weight gain
but what i want to do is i'm going to
just take one little thing in your body
and talk about the effects of sugar on
that one thing and that is going to be
the red blood cells in fact the red
blood cell is how they measure
your blood sugars okay and how they even
diagnose diabetes through a test called
a1c a1c is a test that measures
how much sugar is stuck
to the red blood cell
when the red blood cell or at least the
protein part of the red blood cell
called hemoglobin is exposed to sugar
there's this chemical reaction or
binding that occurs and that's called
glycation so glycation is the amount of
sugar that binds with that hemoglobin
and then renders it
inactive it can't work anymore and so
based on how much
sugar you have stuck to your hemoglobin
can determine what your a1c is so let's
say for example you have an a1c of 5.7
or less
that would be considered normal and so
the term 5.7
just refers to you have 5.7
of the total amount of hemoglobin in
your blood
that is
stuck to this sugar molecule so if it's
between five point seven percent to six
point four percent you're a pre-diabetic
and when it gets over six point four
percent you're a diabetic now what does
all this mean in simple terms
well the red blood cell should normally
be very very flexible it should be able
to hold oxygen and carry oxygen to the
tissues and it shouldn't be very sticky
it should free flow and carry oxygen to
the body and release the oxygen and then
also pick up the co2 and bring that back
into the lungs where it can be
re-oxygenated so the more that this
protein in your red blood cell gets
stuck with the sugar the more your red
blood cells are going to be stiff
it's going to be very very sticky and
it's going to form clumps and so that
increases your risk of getting a clot
but when the red blood cell becomes
stiff it can't bend anymore
so what happens is the blood flows
through your arteries into smaller
arteries and then
tiny vessels called capillaries they get
stuck okay and so we have the arteries
that push the blood down to
the end of your body like the toes and
the fingers and that's where the
capillaries are that then kind of goes
in reverse and becomes the venous system
the veins and then brings the blood back
up through the lungs to start this whole
cycle over so the arteries are filled
with this red blood that's oxygenated
and then as we use the oxygen the return
blood flow to the veins are like a
bluish red because they have less oxygen
but
if your red blood cell
is
not flexible if it's rigid if it's stiff
it can't bend it gets stuck in the
capillaries and then that starves off
the tissues and this is why a diabetic
starts noticing tingling in in the
fingertips and usually the toes or the
bottom of the foot they start feeling an
abnormal uh sensation
like numbness or even pain or
burning what's happening is the blood
cells are too
stiff and they can't seem to get through
the pipes and then we start off the
tissues with oxygen we starve off the
nerves with oxygen and they start to die
that is the first change that happens on
the road to necrosis
or gangrene where the tissues actually
die
and when the tissues don't get oxygen
and they start dying you start having an
increase of
unfriendly microbes it's called
pathogens and unfriendly
fungus
and so when you have gangrene you have a
lot of infection going on
in the body because certain pathogens
thrive in this low oxygen environment
and this is where you get amputation
when someone's a diabetic it starts off
as peripheral neuropathy where the
nerves are affected and then you get the
ulcers and then you start getting
necrosis or dying tissue and then
gangrene and they have to start to
remove different sections of your foot
maybe starting with the toe or the ankle
or whatever so the effects of this
interaction between sugar and this
protein
really messes up the red blood cell it
really
brings down the red blood cells ability
to carry oxygen it also reduces the
volume of red blood cells so think about
this if you're anemic
normally people take iron or b12
but is it really going to work on top of
this problem where your your diet is
very very high in sugar
actually creating or causing the anemia
and then you take some iron is that
going to really help you the answer is
no or another symptom related to not
being able to carry oxygen you're going
to start climbing the stairs and
getting out of breath easier you're
going to have a hard time exercising
because you're not going to have the
wind or the oxygen and so you're going
to get tuckered out really fast and so
you're going to start taking things to
stimulate your energy like caffeine and
things to boost your energy when in fact
you just need to fix the red blood cell
so when these red blood cells
can't fit through the capillaries
the other tissue that affects is the
eyes this is why you have a higher
incident of visual problems
diabetic retinopathy where you actually
can go blind
because you're basically starving off
the nerves that the eye needs to
function
i mean think about what the retina is
it's the extension of your brain it's
all neurological tissue and so it needs
to be fed oxygen through the vascular
system but a lot of different
problems with the eye are related to
this issue of the sugar binding to this
blood cell and the term for it is called
glycation but you have negative effects
to the retina okay so that's going to be
you're not going to see as well you're
going to have problems like glaucoma
cataracts you're gonna have problems uh
macular degeneration so here you are on
a high carb diet and you start to need
glasses because because you can't see so
you just keep getting thicker and
thicker glasses
when in reality you need to change your
diet now another area of the body that's
affected is your gums
um your gums can be more susceptible to
getting an infection it's called
periodontal disease okay
that is another complication of this
problem with the red blood cells you
also have the kidney okay the kidney is
very susceptible to this high level of
sugar because think about what the
kidneys are
they are these mini little filters that
are filtering blood they're like a
capillary type tissue so we're going to
get a lot of destruction in the kidney
and the kidney makes a certain thing
called erythropoietin
which helps make red blood cells in your
bone marrow so if we don't have enough
erythropoietin then we're not going to
generate the number of red blood cells i
mean your bone marrow makes like 2
million red blood cells a second so it's
like a machine that's cranking out these
red blood cells so with the consumption
of sugar you can't make those red blood
cells at the right amount so you become
anemic so you're always kind of tired
and you're always kind of lacking oxygen
especially when you exercise now the
thing that makes your blood red is iron
okay and so when you have this problem
with glycation
the damage
causes the iron to be released from the
red blood cell and then it interacts
with the inside of the artery i mean
think about
when you expose iron to oxygen it rusts
right so now this iron literally creates
a rusting effect because there's oxygen
going on and that
causes little holes in your arteries
okay so it increases the permeability of
the artery and that's where you get
the lesions and the start of plaquing
and clotting
and then what happens is the band-aid is
your body heals it with cholesterol like
a little band-aid and what do people do
they go on a low cholesterol or low-fat
diet is that going to help
no because it's the high carb diet
that's creating the whole thing in the
first place so this is why the low fat
diet of the low cholesterol diet
is not workable for removing plaque in
your arteries so now those are some of
the effects that can be created and i'm
just talking about the red blood cell
now i want to give you a little more
understanding of the significance of
this a1c
as it relates to your blood sugars a1c
is actually a better test in testing
your blood sugars because it gives you
an average of your blood sugars for
about
three months okay and you can even buy
uh home testing kits
to measure your own a1c okay so i'm not
endorsing any any units out there but
you can look them up and buy a test to
measure yourself but the problem with
checking your blood sugars every so
often is that it just shows a snapshot
of what's happening right at that point
the a1c gives you an average of
everything so it's a much more accurate
test for
what's happening on average because
let's say
i don't know you check yourself on
wednesdays and you always eat good on
wednesdays but then the rest of the week
is crappy
you'll pick this up on the a1c test now
a normal blood sugar should be you know
roughly about 80 85 okay milligrams per
deciliter okay and
as far as a1c numbers go
that would be a 4.5
percent a1c okay and so you can see
that's much less than the 5.7 percent
which is kind of the borderline between
normal and pre-diabetes and so as the
blood sugars go up a1c goes up so if
your a1c is 7.0 percent
um your blood sugars are going to be
around 154
but if your a1c is like 13.5
your blood sugars are like over 400 okay
it's very very high now what does this
mean about the quantity
of sugar that you're eating when you
have normal blood sugars which is let's
just say 80 okay 80 milligrams per
deciliter
that is
one teaspoon of sugar
which is roughly about four grams of
sugar
in all of your blood so we have about
seven liters of blood which is about a
gallon and a third of blood and all that
blood one teaspoon of sugar will give
you any reading of 80 okay which is
actually very very small amount of sugar
compared to the amount of sugar that an
average person consumes an average
person in america consumes about 60 to
65 of all of their calories
carbohydrates and these carbohydrates
eventually turn into sugar so that's a
tremendous amount of sugar that is in
our bodies and so if your blood sugars
are 80 which is normal and you're eating
a lot of sugar
how can that be well it's because you
have that hormone insulin that is coming
in they're working like crazy to rip all
that sugar out of your your bloodstream
as fast as you put it in okay but that's
going to catch up with you because
eventually it's going to get
tired the pancreas is going to get
exhausted and then you're going to have
less and less insulin and that's when
the sugars start going higher but just
because your blood sugars are normal
does not mean that sugar is not
affecting other parts of the body
because as the insulin goes up and it
rips out this sugar and puts it where do
you think it's going it's putting in
other places in the body it's it's
turning into a fatty liver it's turning
into problems with visceral fat now this
other point i want to mention is one
teaspoon of sugar is what's in all of
your blood which gives you a normal
blood reading of 80 milligrams per
deciliter right well let's say for
example your blood sugar is
126 okay that's definitely
above normal
how much sugar would is in your blood to
give that reading well it's only one and
a quarter teaspoons so it's not that
much more that is raising it all the way
up to 126
so what you have to realize is it
doesn't take much sugar to raise your
glucose and create a higher a1c so you
might be thinking well i don't eat that
much sugar just just a little bit each
day well you're creating this effect to
the red blood cell so i just wanted to
increase your awareness but when you eat
sugar
and
the following few hours or the day after
and you feel kind of tired or your
vision is off or you get moody now you
know what's happening your red blood
cells are becoming stiffened and they're
being stuck together
so i challenge you to do an experiment
okay in the next
week
just cut out the sugar
and notice
how much more oxygen you have
notice how much more energy you have
because now the red blood cells are a
lot more flexible they can fit through
the capillaries they can actually
deliver oxygen to your tissues which is
a really good thing now if you haven't
seen my video on diabetes which i've
done a long time ago
i think that would be a really good
video to watch now check it out i put it
right here
you